I reject nation and Korea
I'm Greg Alba hi I'm John Humphrey human
of ETS greatly extends past Korea we're
not gonna watch a BTS video what are we
gonna watch John we are gonna watch an
August D video 1/7 of BTS that's right
sugar
his solo music right here this is comes
from none other than who else Natalie
Doran Hopper warranty request
she said sugar from BTS s solo suffer
he's known as a goose T August e a gust
a goose
his rapping style and flow is unreal
Korea's fastest rapper he's actually my
favorite rapper in BTS what am i doing
she's from Ireland
everyone gravitates towards my mine RM
and rightly so but I feel sugar gets
paid dusts and is underrated with the
general public by the way this is so
weird for me calling them other stage
Oertel names
well usually call them by other real
names hahahahaha
[Music]
they're shining
[Music]
damn that was like an onslaught right
there I feel like I just got punched in
the face with bars I didn't watch any of
the video I had watched mostly thus
obtained the chorus when I got used to
the chorus and I started to check out
and I was like okay I got the kind of
just you know this crazy imagery first
he's tied up but then he's like cutting
himself free and wreaking havoc and
being on the back of a armored van yeah
you know we're gonna re-watch the music
video just for ourselves and then we'll
get back to you and right now 2,000
years later
so what I got from this is that sugar
never sleeps he's always working he's
doing all this for BTS and then he does
his solo stuff on the side like he talks
about here how he's working 24/7 I don't
think that's true I mean where's the
downtime where do you find time to dance
practice 16 hours a day and record with
BTS and do all that press with BTS and
don't travel the world and do the
touring of sheets and greets in the
article must be when he's on the toilet
or like the shower he's in the car yeah
he's got like a special pen and paper
made for any little downtime moment I
write my own solo work and I was
impressive he's fast he is very fast
what was that that second verse where
you just went off to the Hong's behind
Hugh monks we're we're Americans have
nothing on us no you hold out-of-touch
brothers yeah yeah you guys don't know
he's gonna take away your income yeah
man hey pop the rhymes you work a lot
better in Korean languages like the
lyrics are actually really cool you know
just the rap is really
I'm heavy and then when you just read it
it does is not fully rhyming of
obviously one like the cleverness of
wordplay through a translation I just
have to imagine like I have to imagine
that for us as listeners we just cannot
possibly get the fullest Xperia not
speaking like I mean know you're on the
beat is awesome and his confidence over
it yeah I love his voice and the flow is
undeniably impressive the lyrics
themselves are pretty bad oh yes
braggadocious is hell
and he is one of those you know you did
a lot of like braggadocious rappers or
aren't even like feels like a
prerequisite like you just have to brag
because that's one of the Wayans in
their video you got fake it to make I
mean you know it's part of the game it's
part of the rap game attitude so I get
it but with him like yeah you're like
the most successful person in the world
right you have more money and more just
at your fingertips perhaps than like
anyone I mean in the chorus he's
revealing he has a sexually transmitted
disease and it really defines him
because he keeps coming back to it I
know it's you spelling his name yes you
know he's talking about wait I had to
put that together he is not talking
about perhaps that is one of those
unfortunate blacks of translations at
the English I think we're the best
American reactors I know plenty of
people cover yes I'm sure we got this
game back to to its best but not this
this dude is is insanely impressive I
don't know exactly how accurate the
translation is he brought up one of his
songs I don't know the name I said to me
and my dumb eye I go so har har-har is a
jato are talking about how he's not too
proud of that song but you know it still
was a major [ __ ]
yeah it's almost reminded me a little
bit of like some M&M attitude like hey
man even though you didn't like this and
still sold a bunch I'm still making my
money I have this this line pulled up
because that is like my favorite it
translates so well here too right if you
want to go ahead by reserving first
class I see is business yours is economy
forever behind me kissing my hand is
such a good yeah plus very relatable
many of us have have written on an
airplane yeah that's true as I remember
when we were watching that BTS come up
video that like 14 minutes
semi-documentary just kind of slap
together for a much a YouTube video si
yeah BTS but especially him well you
know heavily criticized for wanting to
be a rapper and he comes out with [ __ ]
like this you're like this is great what
if he can like really rap battle I'm
wonder if he can first time yeah maybe I
mean like I met a good freestyle but I
wonder if he like can just look like
[ __ ] like rap battle yeah yeah let's
get a rift going in the BTS camp I want
to see RM versus sugar there sugar
versus j-hope yeah and then RM versus
jizz let's get everybody rap battling
each other and I'm sure it has this some
kind of allude to as you come up and the
game as we profession scholars as we
play it a lot of times people that you
admire which I'm assuming is what he's
referring to is that people you admire
who arguably you might have wanted it
like initial respect from suddenly just
don't respect you or probably talk down
on you or something like that oh yeah
well that's been I get the sense of
struggle for them because of yeah the
kpop lame you know the people from me on
their grand hip-hop communities that
they came from you know or not super
kind about that level of success and
that style of music necessarily yeah I
mean he even talks about how is some
people think that it was easy for them
to get here laughing and that's all that
video house like hos is like them
they're sleeping in one room with seven
people in this tiny ass spot you see how
difficult it was for them to get to
where they are just when you become as
famous as them you know
you know like in America they're like
well I've seen them on all these Tata
shows now they're the global phenom yeah
so what the fact that he has the time I
know you usually do that when you leave
the band you don't do that I mean I know
some artists have like throughout
history always done like their own
little solo album short but for
something to this degree this caliber
we´d BTS is at the people like still
making new music and that the touring
all the time yeah yeah like they're not
on break and they'd be coming out with
this stuff it's the work ethic is insane
to me I wonder if he like hits himself
in the morning you must have like
abnormal discipline regimens 4:30 every
morning somebody comes in and tases him
away kind of guy I imagine would put his
forearm on a candle fire breakfast you
put cigars out all down his arm then
snorts a mountain of cocaine seems very
kind well this was great I love this
this is awesome thanks Natalie for
requesting this if you guys liked this
video hit the subscribe button hit the
like button click that notification bell
John does music video reactions three
times a week over at our patreon page I
just show up here for moral support and
make sarcastic comments Natalie just
went to her first BTS concert in person
in a huge Stadium in Britain arse
concert in person first time leaving the
house
way to go Natalie you went as big as you
could I saw some of your Instagram
stories look like you were having an
amazing tiny rest look great or as you
guys say an Ireland crota's Pro tits
remember it all started with the Croats
our protests that's all I had to hear
impact in my life changed my vocabulary
forever
that's what you call me every time I see
go burn yourself people